generation manifeste gleich ob man sehen
hier zum thema und unten der in der
video beschreibung um es dann zu
unterzeichnen und informiert euch dann
natürlich und jetzt den traum mit alles
weniger unterscheiden kann die meckern
aber du hast viel zu tun wir haben wenig
zeit vorher war es so wie jetzt geht's
gleich zur rtl ja woran liegt erzählen
glaube ich hatte die iss auf die lustige
idee gekommen aus meinem buch ist gerade
aus lämmkom ist von dem monat so eine
reportage format zu machen und das höre
ich meine ruhe
ok die scheinen ja was anspruchsvoller
werden zu wollen wallraff hat er jetzt
auch im format
wer weiß das kann dem sinne nicht
schaden würde ich erst mal so sagen kann
man so sagen okay da ist es klar dass
der weltmarktführer der ehemalige
kukident sender ist es marktführer seit
im jahr und das wohnt natürlich die
privaten die belegen warum sind die so
viel erfolgreicher als wir eines echten
der qualität des programms zu tun wer
guckt dann freiwillig noch fernsehen
also ganz ehrlich
also wenn ich krank bin dann guck mal
fernsehen ja ganz jetzt hielt natürlich
zdf also heute show muss man gucken
frontal21 muss man gucken aber ansonsten
gibt es nicht viel muss man gucken musik
du engagierst dich eben du bist nicht
nur schauspieler hast bücher geschrieben
engagiert sich umweltpolitisch überhaupt
politisch und da vor allem ganz aktuell
beim generationen manifest
was ist das denn so wissen die idee die
politik mal ganz kurz aufzudecken
weil die einen ja nun seit jahren so vor
sich hin zwischen euro-rettung und
unfassbaren geschwätz und es folgen
irgendwie dann doch erschreckend wenig
tagen
und ganz ehrlich ob die generation die
am gelackmeierten ist von einem sind
jetzt zu hunderten jugendlichen die sich
vom fernseh gucken bei das kind
verabschiedet haben das heißt der ganze
wahlkampf läuft über medien der
eigentlich an jugendlichen und jungen
leuten total vorbei gibt die lese keine
zeitung also klassisch die welt und die
kein fernsehen und da tummeln sich
ständig diese politiker mit ihren
talkshows und sagen an was alles groß
alex bewegung zu geben
ganz erschreckend wenig und ich denke
wenn es wirklich in zukunft geht müssen
eine politik machen die die jugendlichen
einbezieht und wie natürlich auch den
juden dazu animieren sich politisch in
irgendeiner form zu melden und aktiv zu
werden
was sind die wichtigsten punkte was ich
dem thema umwelt und bildung die
bildungspolitik läuft es nach wie vor so
dass die akademiker kind bist du selber
studieren gehen wenn du kein akademie
kennt ist dass sie nicht studieren gehen
also die durchlässigkeit des
bildungssystems 15 jahren stecken
geblieben und tragisch so hat man den
eindruck wir haben ein wahnsinn
festgefahrenes parteiensystem ist bewegt
sich eben nichts wir haben dieses jahr
fast komplett wahlprogramme man hat den
eindruck da ist nichts mehr drin und das
ist ja auch ein problem deswegen
interessieren sich darüber wenig aus der
jungen generation von politik weil man
den bewegt sich nichts er ist gut ist
eine problematische angela merkel
grundsätzlich die guten wahlprogramme
der parteien aber cloud und das auch
offen zugibt sie sagt also die idee mit
der mietpreisbindung dieses offene spd
aber ich mach das jetzt auch ich glaube
die einzig noch ein bisschen profi haben
und natürlich auch etwas jünger und hier
sind die grünen die manege ganz
pragmatisch sagen wir brauchen ein
plastiktüten verboten
da sage ich schon mal da wo endlich
kommen auf die jemand auf die idee
irgendwas gegen plastik mit zu tun
und natürlich sind es diejenigen die die
alternativen energien am meisten fördern
werden und dafür sorgen werden dass wir
irgendwie aus fossilen brennstoffen
sprich öl gas an dem ganzen atom treck
jemand doch auskommen also ich
persönlich gibt es ganz ehrlich zu ich
wähle grün falls eines ortes jüngste
parteiprogramm ist aber wie kann man
denn überhaupt wo kann man denn dann
dran der partei fest machen wenn die
paar wahlprogramme alle so ähnlich sind
also erstens bin ich gibt es an diesen
unterschiedlichen sich auf kommunaler
ebene politisch engagieren und auf
bundesebene
ich glaube bundesebene wird man
wahnsinnig schnell verschließen genauso
wie die politiker ständig beschweren
ich glaube es gibt doch gar keine
politikverdrossenheit es gibt eine
politik heraus leichter für politik
interessieren sich ganz viele schulen an
nur wenn du dann halt die epigonen
siehst unserer parteien unsere
ehrung verdient mal ganz schnell die
lust und ich glaube dass also ich
persönlich engagiere mich warten nur auf
der kommunalebene weil da kannst du auch
am meisten zu wählen das kann auch
wirklich jeder 20-jährige jeder film und
kann sich auf kommunaler ebene echte
engagieren da gibt's auch wirklich was
zu bewegen als ich bin ich wohne kleinen
dorf da gibt es vor einigen jahren
zwischen daten ob man da ein lidl
supermarkt hin bauen lässt oder nicht
und daran werden maschinen wollen wir
nicht so kleinen geschäfte behalten und
diese die kultur dort schützen
das ist entscheidend für sein das kann
ich nachvollziehen da hast du einfach
das gefühl da gibst du deine hand und
das hatten direkten effekt auf
bundesebene meine sachen verpufft das
sondern irgendwo zwischen lobbyismus und
parteigremien nicht weiß nicht wo aber
dein tipp ist oder sein deine erfahrung
ist schon wenn ich lokalpolitisch
mitmachen kann ich wirklich was bewegen
da muss nicht alles seinen gang gehen
sondern ich kann bestimmen mitbestimmen
der lidl kommt da zum beispiel nicht hin
also das ist auf der kommunalen ebene
zum beispiel ein thema
man muss sich auch man muss eine partei
eintreten zu engagieren ist gewährten
selige nichtregierungs organisationen
und initiativen um mitmachen kann er ich
glaube das einzige was nicht verboten
ist meckern und dann nichts tun also wer
meckert muss sich auch engagieren weil
wir nichts tut hat auch kein rechts
mekka in den 80er jahren gab es viele
bürgerinitiativen
inzwischen hat man nun gibt es
eigentlich noch die wutbürger die immer
gegen irgendetwas sind was gemacht
werden soll und diese dieses gemeinde
denken wir müssen mitmachen und
engagieren oder ist dein eindruck ändert
sich wieder was
oder ist es schwierig ich hab mal gar
nicht gegen wutbürger ich nehme dir
liebe mutbürger und dass gerade die
konservativen auf dem wutbürger so
rumhacken ist natürlich auch die schuld
für mich sind solche beispiele wutbürger
gegen retentionsbecken also becken wo
hochwasser rein läuft und alle anderen
haben probleme also diese mentalität
alles darf sein aber nicht vor meiner
haustür windräder überall hin aber nicht
vor meiner haustür
das ist meine wut bürger sind auch
diejenigen die einschlägigen hart
vorging atomkraft in stuttgart
völlig schwachsinniges projekt absolut
in frankfurt kann man so etwas macht man
bauer im flug bei den bahnhof direkt an
den flughafen und eine schnellverbindung
die stadt was nach stuttgart nein wir
legen diesen monster bahnhofs unter die
erde ist ein genie schwachsinn werden
also ich finde ich unterstütze gewisse
bürgerprojekt und stimmt sich die leute
sind immer so gestritten sagen wasch
mich aber mach es nicht
die grünen in baden württemberg wollen
schrecklich gerne ökostrom haben aber
sie wollen nicht dass ein baum gefällt
wird viel strom fassen das ist natürlich
absolut leute klauen gegen windrotoren
sind klar gegen photovoltaikanlagen sie
machen aber auch keine kohle stinkt
anatom dies gefährlich also manchmal
denk mir die leute wollen die würde mit
einer fackel zurück ist natürlich
quatsch
aber es gibt nach wie vor hervorragende
bürgerinitiativen und ich glaube es muss
auch jeder so sein köpfchen fürs
täglichen finden jeder hat ein gewisses
interesse
manche sind mehr so dritte welt
orientiert manche reihen umweltschutz
mäßig manchmal die menschenrechte es
gibt eines ds gibt human rights watch
man kann sich so auf so vielfältige art
und weise effektiv engagieren dazu muss
ich jetzt nicht unbedingt in einer der
etablierten parteien einsteigen okay
aber oder wann war werden wenn bei dir
der moment wo du gesagt hast ich muss
mich engagieren war das direkt von
anfang an weil ich hab dich hier in
erinnerung in oder du bist das erste mal
als schauspieler begegnet den abwärts
und hab dich überhaupt nicht mit diesem
aktivismus verbunden war das von
vornherein so oder langsamer war das
eine folge seiner prominenz dass du
gemerkt dass haye ich kann damit was
bewegen oder war das schon immer drin
also greenpeace mitglied weiß schon
damals schon gesagt mein die nigerianer
finde es nach wie vor recht wichtige
organisation aber natürlich nutze ich
jetzt mein sonaten promi status ja den
ich ansonsten echt lässt ich finde
natürlich dazu um mit meinen sachen des
fernsehens kommen das heißt mit meinen
dokumentationen über aussteller
tierarten umweltschutz dreier
das hätte ich vor zwanzig noch nicht
machen dürfen natürlich habe sie sehr
viel leichter sondern fernseh
intendanten zu merken als vor 20 jahren
weil wir jetzt kommen sagte harz kommt
dieser letzte jenige aber jetzt ist halt
viel schwerer mich raus zu schwere 2004
also mittlerweile kriege ich halte meine
kleinen dokus weil es ging durch und
kann auch mal ein buch veröffentlichen
und habe natürlich eine andere plattform
als in den tagen wo ich ein unbekannter
schauspieler
das ist der einzige luxus an diesem
status das heißt das war motivation dann
noch mehr zu machen und das richtig
einzusetzen nein ich bin ich arbeiten
diesen medium auf das wir alle mit recht
schimpfen und zu meinem fernsehen ist zu
90 prozent total verblödung aber du
kannst eben auch clever nutzen
es gibt diesen jährlichen satz fernsehen
macht dumm und dümmer und kluge klüger
und es stimmt ja stimmt im fernsehen
gucken kannst du dich aber bestens
unterhalten viel lernen dich informieren
wenn es einfach laufen lässt erste
tatsächlich ist ja quasi
werbefinanzierte gehirn amputation
aber du kannst gerne etwas andere nutzen
ich habe eine sommer 30 jahre
fernsehunterhaltung gemacht und viel
unterhaltung und habe mir überlegt
vielleicht kann ich das noch zu etwas
anderem nutzen und das versuche jetzt
ein paar lernen dabei auch wieder erfolg
danke vielen dank wählen gehen
das dümmste ist nicht wählen gehen das
muss ich noch los